all right Buffett time for the other end
of the spectrum well I did my top 10
best episodes written by Steven Moffat
and now it's time for the 10 worst
episodes written by Steven Moffat now
before we get into this quick little bit
of business I have a sponsor it's myself
and by that I mean I now have t-shirts
available on t public there's a link
down in the description and I'm kind of
pushing this right now because when the
design first goes up it is discounted
and that lasts not particularly long so
if you're seeing this the day that it
goes out if you have any interest in a
t-shirt with the Council of geeks logo
on it I would recommend buying sooner
rather than later there that's it I've
sponsor myself I have no issues shilling
my own merch cuz nobody else is gonna
sponsor me anyways back to business
quick reminder of the ground rules I am
only tackling episodes that he has the
sole writing credit on nothing where he
is a co-writer also keep in mind two
parters count as a single story also I
realized while compiling this list that
much like when I looked at Russell T
Davies most of the episodes that he
wrote himself tend to be pretty good so
they're gonna be ones at the not worst
end of this that actually aren't even
all that bad even are some I enjoy and I
guarantee you there's gonna be a couple
of episodes in here that I'm gonna list
on a worse list that people will
genuinely like but I have to look at the
entire man's work and I had to fill out
10 and this is what I came up with so
that having been said let's start with
number 10 deep breath the very first
outing for Peter Capaldi's doctor there
there are a number of things that throw
this off then and there are as is gonna
be the case with most of these there are
some good things going on here
capaldis doing pretty good him looking
at his reflection and going who fried me
this face is a great moment the the
Paternoster gang is fine they just seem
like they're kind of there and they were
thrown in
the dinosaur is a complete waste like
what an awesome setup at an awesome
premise if there's a huge dinosaur in
the middle of London and then they just
burn it
like I don't assign from the fact that
that is a cheap and lazy way to remove
an something that otherwise you'd have
to spend most of the narrative trying to
fix it's cruel that thing didn't want to
be there it didn't bring itself there
and it burns alive yeah well not not
alive to death
no the bring back of the robots you know
and the sort of taking human beasts is
like it's not a bad idea again I'm not
sure that that callback actually adds
anything and while Capaldi does have his
moments I just feel I do feel in general
overall that his time in series eight is
where he is at his weakest at least for
what I like about his time as the doctor
so between all those yeah that comes in
at number ten number nine time abhi
angels in flesh and stone and I know
that this one's got to take a lot of
people off but look I've got a couple of
problems with this episode and again
there is good stuff the whole concept of
the well the whole scene of a me looking
at the image of the angel and that
starts moving in ways that it shouldn't
be that's awesome epic brilliant the
angel Bob thing it's a little cheesy but
kind of works of course wherever is
always fun to have on hand but look I
know this kind of stuff is nitpicky but
it really does eat away at me and mostly
it has to do with the Angels so there's
little things like the fact that you
know one of them grabs the doctor's coat
and you know freezes as a statute why
who was looking at it why did it freeze
at that moment there's no reason it
should have the fact that there isn't
even like a hint at how we saw them
taking people out before now it's just
oh now they just straight-up kill you
I'm like well okay so like why like if
if they if what they did with the whole
zapping people back in time was to feed
off their energy I mean I know they're
there for a much bigger energy source
but like why wouldn't they also just do
that it seems
like a waste of energy that you could
have by killing people outright
instead of just snapping them back in
time again so I don't get that but
ultimately the the big thing with me in
this is and this is the same problem I
have with revelation of the Daleks this
plot would have resolved itself if the
doctor had just never showed up
seriously think about it
he doesn't do anything to actually
defeat them all that happens is he
realizes that the fact that they were
draining the energy from the ship means
they are going to defeat themselves all
he does is tell everybody else to hold
on if they had never shown up this thing
would have fixed itself there is no
point in him being there whatsoever
renders the whole story pointless and as
good as parts of it and the cast
including the guest cast are in it
that's a big problem for me number eight
the wedding of River Song this was one
that at the time that I dared I was like
it's pretty good I guess it's kind of
fun
and it is kind of fun but it's also all
over the place the whole thing I mean
like the concept of time is so broken
that everything is happening at once is
a really cool idea but there isn't
really much done with it except for a
few kind of wonky kind of funny visual
gags at the front end of it you know and
it's an excuse to bring back a whole
bunch of guest stars who otherwise would
have no business appearing in the same
episode it's very contrived and the
solution the whole thing with the the
robot the tesselecta think it's I don't
know if it's quite deus ex machina but
it's close and I think for me the most
infuriating thing is that you teased
that this was the point that he told
River his name and that isn't what
actually happened so we actually never
find out how it is that she learns the
doctor's name which I actually wouldn't
have a problem with I don't need to know
that except yeah highlighted it
repeatedly that she knew his name and
that's a big deal
she knew his name and she should never
have found out that what his name was
and you you you did all these very
blatant pointed teasing's about that and
then teased an answer that you don't
give us that's just being a dick
number seven a Christmas carol I
actually do consider this to be pretty
decent as far as the Christmas specials
go but I've said in the past I'm
actually not a huge fan of the Christmas
specials and this is really cheesy I
mean the show can't be cheesy they can
even be cheesy in a good way sometimes
like I consider robot of Shorewood to be
an episode that's cheesy in a good way
but this thing is trying to go for
emotional weight and impact at the same
time that it has flying fish and it is
it is using as a template one of the
best known Christmas stories ever to the
point that it actually shares the title
and it's it's not unclever in terms of
having the doctor play ghost of past
present and future
thanks to time travel and timey wimey
meanness and you know that's not an
awful way to spin it but it isn't really
enough of a new spin to be worth telling
the umpteenth you know adaptation of a
Christmas carol Amy and Rory get
sidelined and honestly when you stop and
think about it for a while the whole
just ethics of the doctor fundamentally
alters somebody's past with the
intention of changing who they are as a
person that's a little uncomfortable and
doesn't really get addressed properly I
don't think number six the bells of st.
John so yeah honestly my major gripe
with this is the version of Clara we got
stuck with both versions of Clara that
we got prior to this are more
interesting than this version just by
virtue of the fact that they broke the
young woman from Modern London template
that she is absolutely 100% falling into
the whole thing with the the Wi-Fi is I
guess it's kind of an interesting idea
but it's weird and the visualization of
like the spoon heads is
I don't know if it's supposed to be crew
creepy it's just kind of odd and I'm not
sure it really it really does it for me
I do like the reveal of the great
intelligence that's like kind of a cool
capper to have on the end of it but
that's that's about it overall this
episode is really forgettable so little
of it sticks in the mind besides you
know scooped out metallic back of the
heads and oh great intelligence is back
okay number five the time of the doctor
I really don't like this episode very
much at all I think it was a mistake to
take this tone in this mood with a
regeneration story especially one that
is an extra length episode as opposed to
you know the normal 45 minutes because
the whole thing has this meandering
almost bedtime story fairy tale like
quality which normally is a vibe I
really dig but the thing about a
regeneration story because we always
know that this is the regeneration then
I am of the opinion that the best way to
get through with that and get us there
and have us enjoy the ride to the moment
that we're all waiting for is by having
is by getting us wrapped up in something
and that's what Russell T Davies tended
to do you know that's what he did
definitely with Tenon's you know this
big epic adventure and all the
companions are bagging you get wrapped
up in all this stuff and it keeps you
entertained while you're waiting for the
final you know the the end where we get
the regeneration and this episode
doesn't really do that it just kind of
did - there's your regeneration it's
just the slow pondering not especially
inherently interesting thing and I think
it's completely the wrong mood if this
episode was not a regeneration story
honestly I probably liked it a heck of a
lot better but
a generation story I just think it was a
bad call number four the Beast below I
think largely my problem with this
episode is its placement we this is only
the second story we've got with this
doctor and in the second story his first
trip offworld with Amy Pond they try and
give us a story where he gets mad at her
tells her he's leaving her home after
this and goes through a hole humans are
awful and terrible and to heck with all
of you moment and it's not earned it's
too soon we meet we need to know him
better we need to know that that we need
to be more invested in him and Amy that
the that him saying forget it it's over
is actually gonna mean anything we need
to get a better understanding of what
his normal expectations of humans is if
we're going to by him being this
infuriated with them because we do start
almost from scratch with every doctor so
this thing's going for emotional weight
that it hasn't earned it's way too early
in this guy's run to be pulling this
kind of stuff and then as a general
premise you know the space whale is kind
of weird and is results in this whole
slavery the animal rights thing that
doesn't really feel like a properly
fully developed idea I feel like the
smilers are a really good look in search
of a purpose or a function there are
still some neat ideas and this the idea
of you know citizens having to make what
is an awful choice but then making it so
they don't have to live with that choice
because they don't remember making it
you know that's that is a cool idea but
that's like kind of the core cool idea
it's just surrounded by stuff that is
just kind of there number three the
snowmen so first off this version of
Clara better than the one we got at
least initially and I like her I like
her dynamic I like how quick what did
she is I like that there's a certain air
of mystery about her I like her
namek with the doctor and that whole
thing is about the entirety of what I
particularly like you know the Pater
Noster gang is fine in this but I feel
like in hindsight more often than not
they are the best parts of not great
episodes the snowmen the titular snowmen
look ridiculous are not intimidating if
they keep recycling the exact same
effect over and over and over again and
they are they do barely anything they
eat a couple of extras basically the
whole iced copy is a really weird and
bizarre idea it doesn't look especially
good the casting of Ian McKellen as the
voice for the great intelligence was a
masterstroke but he doesn't do much and
then Richard he grant as dr. Simeon it's
completely wasted he's great when he
gets to come back as the embodiment of
the great intelligence later but here it
is a complete waste of his talents this
is there are some episodes of Doctor Who
that managed to balance and get
transitions from from goofiness and
comedy into seriousness and drama and
tragedy even you know making that
transition from one mood to another
almost seamlessly this is not one of
them you can feel the gears grinding
every time it switches from something
light and funny and then it tries to go
for scary or tries to go for pathos and
it's just not working
number two the doctor the widow and the
Wardrobe
now I actually liked this episode better
than I think a lot of people do mainly
because I like Madge I think she's great
I think the performance is right I think
her dynamic with the doctor is great I
love the sort of nature of the
relationship with her being motherly
towards I mean not necessarily in a
caring way like a go clean your room way
like who acts like that was the doctor I
really do like her she's kind of it
though I mean the rest of it I don't
even know what it's riffing on cuz like
the the title is evocative of narnia but
all we get for that is they kind of
wander through this opening and oh
there's trees and it looks like it's
Christmas and then
that illusion means nothing beyond that
the whole thing with the trees and the
mothership it's it's one of those things
that's it's oddly poetic and I get what
they were going for but that sort of
level of poetic resolution doesn't quite
work in Doctor Who
it doesn't overplay it as badly as a
force of the night did which isn't on
this list because Moffat didn't write it
but it's committing a similar sin it's
going for a thematic metaphorical
lyrical poetic sort of resolution to
everything that doesn't really make a
ton of sense and you know I can
sometimes roll that better than others
and like I said I don't I don't
personally have a massive dislike for
this episode but I still acknowledge it
is not it's not good it has a lot of
problems they are they are legion and
really Maja's about the only good thing
and I may be the only one who even likes
that part of it so yeah there's that and
the number one worst episode of Doctor
Who written by the esteemed Steven
Moffat hellbent if you are a longtime
viewer of this channel this might come
as a slight surprise to you because this
will be my third time talking about this
episode specifically my assessment of
hell-bent has gone through a little bit
of a journey very first time that I
watched it I was just confused I did not
know what it was that I had just watched
I didn't know what to make of it I
didn't think I liked it but I also felt
like I can't even justice cuz I don't
know what it is and then through some
comments on that video I came to a
better understanding of what it was and
then initially I thought better of it I
mean I thought oh okay
well I see what it's going for now and
for some reason for a little while at
least I gave it more of a pass because I
now understood it and it kind of
succeeded at what it was trying to do
I've soured on it since then because I
think what it was trying to do was a fun
mentally stupid awful idea that just
that not only undermines what comes
before it undermines two of the best
episodes of definitely that series and
saw him one of the best episodes of new
who as far as I'm concerned it
completely undermines the death of Clara
and face the Raven and it completely
undermines heaven-sent because yes he's
trying to escape from the confession
dial whatnot but it's a metaphorical
story because he's processing his grief
that his grief is creeping behind him
that's what the monster is so you had
this wonderfully well built-up tragic
death you had a follow-up episode that
focuses on the grief and the pain of
that and then she's alive and she's fine
and no having the doctor not remember
her does not work as a substitute for
the grief that we watched him go through
in heaven said it's not equivocal you
are undermining what you just did
and then we have recast Rassilon and an
actor I usually like but he doesn't have
anywhere near the gravitas that Timothy
Dalton brought to the point that I'm
just I'm just left thinking we shouldn't
have even had revisited the character
the the fact that the doctor shot
somebody he shot somebody I don't care
that he knew that person was gonna do
regenerate he has said in the past you
know maybe it was just tenant but he has
made at least once the comparison of
regeneration to death he killed that
incarnation of that Time Lord the doctor
shot someone with a gun and they died no
I don't care if you're trying to go look
how far he'll go for Clara you don't do
that with this character and on that
subject how far he goes for Clara let's
examine that a little bit allow me to
explain why I hate that so I don't love
Clara I've never loved Clara she did
grow on me over time and like I said her
death and paced the Raven
beautiful wonderful completely tragic I
even as someone who didn't like her like
that is good that was good and I'm not
like oh I wanted her tonight like that
is a good beautiful exit but to have him
go to the lengths that he goes to to
bring her back is mofat beating the
audience over the head with the idea
that she is the most important person in
his life ever look at the length he's
willing to go to look at the rules he's
willing to break look at the lines you
lunge across that he never crossed for
any other companion in the history of
this show it's her because she's the
best well that's what I say to you
Moffat you don't get to tell me who the
best companion is because that's what's
great about this show we get to decide
who the best doctor is for us we get to
decide who the best companion is for us
you don't get to dictate for us that
Clara is best just because you fell in
love with your own creation and wouldn't
let her die after you gave her a great
beautiful death no yet to undermine
everything and then completely throw
under the bus the entire narrative that
you build up about the idea of doctor of
the doctor getting back to Gallifrey
that gets literally tossed aside again
sacrificed on the altar of look how
great Clara is and what he goes through
to bring her back and it wasn't even a
case of like that was set up by Davies
and he didn't want to deal with it that
was Moffat
plotline he set that up himself and then
he threw it away for this o Hume off it
and that is wow it's been a while since
I talked about that episode I think I'd
worked up a fresh load of bile towards
it and that is my thoughts on what I
feel is the worst darkroom episode a
Steven Moffat ever wrote and it honestly
makes me so angry it has a really good
running you have what I think might be
the worst episode of the show ever and
again if you're a longtime viewer that
might be weird because I left it off the
last one I did a 10 worst episodes of
new who as a whole because it had aired
point but like I said my loathing of
this episode has been a journey and it's
a journey of hatred right now so those
are my thoughts that's my list what are
your thoughts I'm sure your list is
different I'm sure like I said some
people are gonna see episodes they love
that I just slagged off so whatever your
thoughts are just spare the personal
attacks if you could but drop them down
in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to do all those things you
know the things the likes and subscribes
and Twitter follows in podcast listens
in patreon support maybe links for all
that stuff's down below if you want to
check it out and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]